[Music]
danielle joins us up next in st louis
danielle welcome to the show
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call absolutely what's going on
well i am just starting out um i started
june 3rd and um went right into baby
step two
i guess i have a two-part question um
first i am
struggling with figuring out the budget
aspect of it i know they you guys say it
takes about three months and i'm
starting to see it working out a little
better
but i
just am having trouble with figuring out
how to have patients
and not pay all my bills right up front
on that first paycheck and then waiting
and not having any money when i get to
my second paycheck oh so you're draining
the checking account
right away overzealous
okay my bills
so that's part of it and then i also
just feel like i need
um a goal um of when i should be having
like how much i should be paying towards
it so i can be out of debt by a certain
point hang towards the debt
when i should be out of baby step two do
you have margin right now my numbers
um so i
uh take home about 2500 a month for my
primary job
and i just this week started a part-time
for nights and weekends job where i'll
probably be taking home about 600 800
extra a month right
and i am doing doordash on occasion as
well so probably about a hundred to 300
a month from that
as far as what i have in debt
and i have um just under 42 000 to go
so
that is
uh 4 800 i'm sorry 4200 is credit cards
um 32 000
is student loans
and i also have a car fleece or about
5500 still to go okay
cool about halfway through that so let's
get to your budgeting question
you can change a lot of the dates the
bills are due on and so if you're
experiencing that you can go in online
or call them and say hey i want this
bill to come out on the 16th
and i want this bill to come out on the
18th and that way you can control some
of these variables in your budget do you
have any buffer in your checking account
um well that's what i'm also trying to
figure out is how to
put that in my
in my budget so that i have leftover
money at the end of the month
because i know you said you probably
need about 100 to 300
as a cushion so i'm trying to figure out
how to play that so i can just save that
in my checking account first and
foremost so you said your take-home pay
is 2500 what are your expenses if you're
doing this budget
have you added that up
if you add in all your minimum payments
on your debts
minimum payments on my debt
is about
550
and i've been trying to pay about um 850
to 900 a month okay so you have about
three four hundred bucks of margin right
now to throw at the debt
yes and you're going to start these side
hustles which will bring in another
thousand and so that's going to really
speed up this process i mean that'll you
make it happen three times as fast
that's what i'm hoping
i love it so are you using every dollar
right now or you have a different
budgeting method that's working for you
i'm i started financial peace and i'm
using um the premium every dollar oh
awesome okay well i was going to gift it
to you so you beat me to the punch thank
you
and so your second question was what
um
so i just want to have a goal i know it
has it in the in the app but i just feel
like
it's telling me 2027 and i just feel
like wow
unreasonable what is your yearly income
um
well i just have my primary i don't know
about the others but my primary is about
four just under 49 000. okay what do you
do
i am an accounts receivable so i post a
lot of payments
why do you do accounts receivable
why
well
i don't know
do you love it i
i don't hate it
i i am a money person
if i said do you love your spouse you're
like i don't hate them honey do you love
me i don't hate you john i don't hate
you actually i have gotten that response
before
um here's what i'm saying
money goes one of two ways you get more
on the front end or you stop spending
less on the back end right and so
you're a money person you know how money
works i'd love to see you double your
income whether you go be an assistant
cfo or go
yeah but your whole call you're asking
like i don't like you're a money person
you're an accounts receivable you have a
degree in this stuff and you're asking i
don't oh you don't okay so you've got
experience let me say that you've got
experience in it
um
you're not suffering from knowledge
issues you're suffering from confidence
issues where does this come from
um
i'm i i'm not sure
part of it is i feel like i'm not in the
right career path yeah
my 32 000 in student loan debt is for a
degree i'm not really using what's your
degree part of that my degree was in
media communications with public
relations as um my track okay can i tell
you the accountants that i've worked
with and there's been a bajillion of
them
that can talk to me and explain what
they're actually doing
it's invaluable
and they make their way up the ranks the
the two cfos here at ramsey are two of
the coolest funniest hilarious guys and
they know how excel works which makes
them like unicorns right
and so you have a degree in media
community you have a degree in
communicating with other people and you
know how numbers work see what i'm
getting at you didn't waste your degree
in fact you've got a set of skills now
that people in your field are short on
that makes you very valuable see i'm
saying i'm trying to find ways to give
you confidence here
and not this i don't even know how to
like what's the math problem you do math
for a living you know right
i don't know what's holding you back
yeah i don't know i guess i just don't
know
i i love the place where i work and so i
guess i have some hesitance in finding
new employment
and you can love another place too
you know you don't love going home every
night not able to sleep because you owe
so much money
yes and you don't love getting off an
accounting job that you've been working
on five days a week to only work
weekends and nights
and then drive on sunday mornings
because you're broke
right
and danielle as part of your membership
you have access to the debt snowball
tool so start plugging in all of your
numbers and add in that extra income and
i guarantee you it's not going to be
five years for you to pay off this debt
looking at these numbers and what your
new take-home pay is going to be even if
you stayed in this career my guess is it
takes two years okay and that's i mean
that's conservative i think you can do
better than that so make it a personal
competition with yourself to see how
much more maybe you need to recheck all
of your insurance coverage and say am i
overpaying go check with xander
maybe go make sure you're not getting a
tax refund we need to change our
withholding to put more money back in
our budget every single month so start
doing those things make sure you've
paused investing so that you're not
having a money leak over there while
you're trying to pay off debt go do a
budget audit get super nerdy which you
know you know how to do that really well
and i think you're going to feel the
progress and you go where else can i
start shaving some money i'm not going
to eat out i'm going to go to aldi
instead of publix just get creative with
it and see what kind of traction you
make and i it kind of gets addictive
john can i give you a secret like a life
hack
yes bring it on confidence is not
something you think yourself into
confidence is something you
you achieve your way into
i'm gonna practice these things so i
want you to do a 30 day sprint where
you're going to work like crazy and save
as much as you can don't go out to eat
don't go do crazy things don't rent a
movie just do 30 days and send that
check and see how that feels and that
should give you a hit of confidence and
confidence and it's going to grow over
time the more you stay invested in this
game